the Joe Rogan experience train my day
Joe Rogan podcast by night okay no idea
what fine morning
there's no no concept of it yeah it's on
the app ban becomes like a little join
the levels are SATs you said is in a
little tightly home so - I know it is
Widow get low enough this where's I'm
not mr. Jeff I'm not with this is what
it is is shit depression I don't mind
you're putting the pressure on yourself
right now thank you for my fucking money
back from Catholics yeah you actually
pay that my brother take that around
I'll let you find something nasty and
spells rude
like religion so fun no it isn't no we
we Jews have a decent few G's are way
better sense of humor with chapters to
the UH athletes all about suffering hey
daddy they return the they return the
radiators on in the summer and
return moth it's like why something I'll
do the dish yeah that's a real thing I
trust my be my head over the water
coffee cowboy probably I drink a
separate again you know the up I like
the coconut oil and coffee thing it's
good
it's good just doesn't regular coconut
water oh yeah just coffee sure they just
went up enough those equal one that one
right there I think he called your shit
talking today cybela blend really it's
okay I see
again NASA patches Ronda Rousey's real
Ronda Rousey's way hotter than her patch
the only female UFC fighter don't give
the shit up is she's hot
was it Gina Carano also right now she's
act like Jesus Ike yeah she's dead
Roots maybe not ruff maybe not this
grouping though yeah just when I'm all
close together easier that way like he
was saying I was planning on fusion mile
an hour it's good to know that the exact
same shot about a wearing
nice
our Twitter
and put like I was like oh that's good
to this podcast think they thought I
meant like right now this second or
something yeah people get angry they're
entitled Matt they want young really
long in front of all their money that's
not gonna need you need to be up there's
not enough free content from this
everywhere they're people being such
dicks about the NBC hmm like well that's
the definite like it's going to be
online later the same show like well I
don't like the idea they had broadcast
NBC in his country I'm like to Ukraine
out that CEO you might have got what I
needed like if I get angry when I'm
already down yeah yeah so we got yo
working sucks let you fuckin 70 jobs
sheep yourself some up okay joy should
you smooth that must have greatness you
see you used to be some special pearl
your fucking chill sellout
how's that feel how soft this
rationality will totally one day the
password are smoking tire County and
lash out all you want
yeah comedian comment is a problem no
it's not
I just jump off start under I would love
to do that under in Thomas account yeah
just torture me
done my lung you got what into the same
you know whether you like hockey
no no I got a piggy getting better
recordings let me fucking mobile all
right dirty fucks will be back soon
Rogan teen.com go there save twenty five
bucks on the new Android device the the
sexiest of the sexy including the HTC
One m8 which I have my dirty little
eyeballs on dink dink dink
thanks to on it comm go to onn I T use
the codeword Rogan and save 10% off of
any and all supplements for limited
edition kitty cat t-shirts and all of
the information about podcasts and any
of Brian's comedy dates go to death
squad TV and get your freak on including
this Friday night will be at the Ice
House in Pasadena in the little room
doing an episode of thunderpussy which
is a completely improvisational podcast
the audience yells out ideas and go on
stage blitz out of your fucking mind and
you talk mad shit and it's probably the
funnest thing I've ever done in my life
are you around Friday night I'm in
Village go fuck yourself feeling
pressure from me
howdy bill burr was right you thought
necessary like much love big kiss to
everybody
I'm not those football it's a walk spot
real jets anyway let's get back College
yeah let's find right pulls a blast I
would have a pool table of our people
I love having one in your studio firstly
this one this is from the nineteen
seventies it's a gold crown too
Oh
oh hi ball goes in and you scratch you
don't win you stick my mother the time
Volga Scarponi that ball and anywhere on
the table all right well you have a
nightmare it's not a victory you have a
one ball that's wide open but two balls
tied up at the 8th you don't play two in
combination and then but all I'm through
is go off with one ball right yeah I
mean if you can possibly knock those
balls free once you make the one ball
you see last comic standing and doing no
no's are they good
I heard it's better but Roseanne is
getting Russell Peters this is behind
the scenes but just you're resilient
archetype Sigmar might make them a
breakout star commit to be shimmy shoe
mindful yeah yeah yeah I'm going on
every month you've gone well you know
what's his face as the host JB Smoove
yeah whose whole Larry yeah that's a
great move I love him that guy's funny
as shit I read it in Whole Foods I read
as I do that I know we're at Whole Foods
he's cool as fuck to him on that but
Kirby enthusiam yeah yeah he's a funny
guy
hey counts on the thanks for doing
thunderpussy Friday so if you talk cow
it is yeah oh I'll get them in yeah
burr crushes your shot sexy bitch get in
here come on coming we should get some
pretty soon that dude had the funniest
fucking story last night I was how piss
in my pants yeah oh yeah let's go yeah
you see didn't get him Joe's number he's
coming back to live here though June
first or something
on the show no I think they're good
confer just done for some Lewis gym
seasons for a few sports they want to me
thanks all the way down Joe yeah yeah
text me his number so if they start
selling tickets for Friday night yeah is
it sold out yeah I mean chef they play
to have the opposite of Memorial besides
this one I'm very cool what this is your
shot you came into one ball bitch just
like it's my job yes yeah made eight
ball go by your fuck still good luck kid
you'll make drunk people I've talked to
her convinced they're gonna pool
it's quite fascinating ready reverse
jump I'm totally ready
one ball inside pocket okay so I'm going
anywhere near the sidewalk my chest
watch it seems like the universe's this
is ever seemed like pools a good person
that knows I play Bowl it's all it does
it does they believe their shots
seriously
oh yeah I can do it too if I fall on
there
then we can ask you a question sorry did
you go for the fog ball that way as
opposed to this way because it would be
due to Photoshop I have two shots I five
months I was possible or five all here
the problem playing the size would have
hit it lighter yeah but I didn't come
back properly because I have a bad angle
I honestly if I did want to come back I
would want to have an angle just about
two inches that way so that I could stay
on this side of the ball because that's
how it scares me right there no it's not
scary but the side pocket I couldn't I
know well I'm not going to play now I'm
playing because of the angle I'm
planning to come down here and then
shoot this ball in a side pocket because
the angles not good the pool when you
play a certain level it's all about
maintaining the correct angle to go from
one ball to the other ideally I would
have liked to stop anywhere around right
here so funny I would have stopped I
wouldn't try to stop here yeah cuz I
want that shot as opposed to the next
well that's good too but I wanted to
once I make the ball I want to wind up
right right here and where it's out
right now it's very hard to do that
because where it's on right now the
natural angle of shooting the ball in
its going to make the ball go this way
so now I have to adjust to that and I
have to make the ball go this way
and then out here so I have to hit it
and I hit updated with low right hand
English so that when it hits the table
and hits the rail bounces off and gets
good
the other thing that I noticed is
whenever I pray I bring with Tom English
you do that but I've only broken that
way I've never broken you broke you
broke using the bottom it doesn't matter
if you can stop the ball I like to use
bottom but some people like these tops
of plows to balls when you hear someone
say they're good at pool you're like oh
but how good are you
I just hope I don't get left with an
easy shot and I can't make that right
that's one of those things where I find
that like we're talking about like
archery a little play yeah that's one
shot did what people do archery you got
a cat
you do a bunch oh no I'm good I'm gonna
get out of here buddy
good funny man liver disease this whole
other side of my body
why did you know where your liver